yeah welcome to this video this is
something new yeah I was some this is a
spontaneous idea not sure if this is
going to be something regular but you
never know the idea is that last Monday
I played a session of the war the
typical one hour Monday live session for
the ICC and someone requested that I
should play a little bit of yeah unusual
openings for me and um yeah I thought it
was a fun session it went very well
actually and so my idea is I'm going to
once in a while play a session of three
miniatures three-minute blitz it's a bit
quicker than and also it's mint and a
little bit more Yun light-hearted way
not something super serious i'm going to
play on yap some more adventurous
openings there so it's kind of a don't
try this at home show yeah okay it will
be like 20 to 30 minutes session of
three minute games and kicking me off
standing right here my rating is not
super higher there two thousand two
hundred and playing you on Westerberg
yeah what can I do I can't start with
that but I'm going to play in a sharp of
Hessian um he came let's see what we get
yeah it's difficult to play really sharp
here maybe I can angle for some kinks I
play yeah I wanted to play him I wanted
to play a 5 based stuff the Schliemann
ants and things like that but it doesn't
seem to materialise him because he went
Bishop c4 difficult to play something
really funky there but okay that's not
bad at all and I'm going to try to play
aggressively and quickly it's three
minutes yet so i have to be a bit
quicker than usual okay if i go f 5 i'm
really be kidding myself so
all ideas of playing a bit crazy are
nice but you still have to be M Gabby
sound okay Bishop c2 and then if five is
maybe something but I didn't have any
particular choice and as mentioned i
have to be have to be quick so tix okay
it just has a check though it's not
nothing dangerous in particular d 5 i'm
going back to the eighth I don't see any
a huge problem with that okay I still
has 23 I was thinking that this some
rock d 8 will help but in fact it
doesn't okay so here's this check them
hmm yeah and five doesn't help okay I
can play rook e8 I think I'm not mated
or anything Queen h7s is a check but not
sure if it is much more than that check
okay don't know I mean I can go here
night you form okay ticks and Queenie 64
Queen g6 maybe I mean that's not ideal
but I don't feel okay I'm just taking
this right what a surprise see the
problem I'm just taking that
Queen age six Bishop g7 should be fine
okay one minute 29 left at the time as
something that I have to keep in mind
i'm really used to five minute chest
three minute is not what i usually do ok
well the heels here is just a piece down
um I can take five even but not sure
that I want okay let's keep the a pawn
and now maybe take it don't see why not
okay this runs into night h7 so not a
good idea time warning
yeah cantique only five didn't he simply
didn't okay man let's go back age five
Queen f6 we take c5 now I can take a
play f6 so what is it that he has
ultimately I could have played 93 maybe
hmm maybe yeah now he's taking some time
I can still do that I mean you can take
c7 butt cheeks he ever take it with
chick hmm that's true okay the time it
really might be Jack big issue at the
end I'm not used to that
I cannot take age 6 because of the check
on e 1 and Queen f4 is winning for me I
think I think jack oops chechik like
another chick okay I've got 20 seconds
and this is 5 pounds 5 x is really a lot
check hmm Jack might be might be too
much ultimately okay I got that one
check check check check check and check
check and it was sent the presence of
mind to take that amazing with
absolutely no time on the clock black
465 yeah I got 30 moves in but it didn't
help yeah okay I shouldn't lose that at
the end but ok it was just a click fest
yeah around TM it's just a draw but ok
10 seconds against 12 is tricky okay new
game in this session started no cool i'm
going me fall I'm out for those for
those aggressive lines here we go f4
against the lands defense which is going
to be tricky I have no idea about this
that's it split it sir what wow wow
that's a line hard to believe okay night
be 5 i'm going to get killed a cheek ok
let's try that that looks really strange
ok let's keep the pawn their depot
namine and ok we protect that IDK ok
well this is just an opening and opening
failure for black I mean I always have
to be cautious there because I don't
know it it might be a great line that I
simply don't know but this is really
just good for white
attacking me six them yeah maybe he has
Bishop b5 something like that but I can
really just play I can't just play this
and casts a long next for a great
position yeah okay you cannot take a two
obviously he is getting killed with 95
then so my day too is not on and yeah
i'm going to take care that is that that
should work if not something is really
wrong here with this game plan yeah
that's just just just over rook takes
Bishop takes root check and see 5 and
he's getting killed yeah that's just I
don't want to do much analysis here just
a good good 20-30 minutes of quick fun
so trying to play in an aggressive way
then started ok here we go we form sir
john yeah can I go can I cannot cannot
play the more I hear Mary Queen takes
can also be quite aggressive oops ok
yeah I wonder canceling short or long in
this position hmm I have no idea I think
short might be more the more solid
choice can I get my Knight to f5 I'm
trying he might have naughty form ok it
didn't sorry he didn't test that maybe
he had this opportunity ok let's get out
of this and maybe even f3 just to
stabilize that he still he cannot cancel
short as age 6 is hanging night h5 I
have g3 I don't mind that so much I was
thinking this him how does he protect
the H pawn
maybe he can play d5 hmm the typical
Sicilian break taking age 6 is this too
bad too might be bonkers but normal
moves don't don't do it they simply
don't this might be bad but at least it
is messy ok Knight g4 is the big problem
if I take with the knight on f3 he's
going to play night chief form a chick
with the palm hmm yeah night h5 I have
Bishop g5 at least that's not good
really but at least as much as I said
it's a bit messy at least always playing
that anyway that's enterprising because
of the pin here hmm yeah he's right he's
right ok I have to take even even if
it's losing has still have to take it ok
but if i take here let's let's think
about this if i go Bishop g7 what is
this move I'm out for Bishop takes e5
let's of course pure coincidence I
didn't plan any of it and now Bishop f5
queen is seven is holding is holding but
ok I have to take not much not much
choice queen is seven unfortunately I
don't have a good move now comuna for
something maybe Adam I don't really have
a good move as i said i have to get out
of this this kind of self painting
situation on the e-file 94 is a move
maybe at something that looks a nice if
i can get it in let's
that time warning non-threatening g5 may
be cutting this bishop oh he's giving me
the Queen yeah people tend to make
mistakes when they are irritated and now
think i managed that at least even if it
wasn't any good it was so it was
irritating check check okay let's make
sure I'm not getting back rank meted
there was a lucky winner of course I was
just totally totally busted him
black reason yeah that was how was a
lucky one but yeah it's mentioned
sometimes purely being irritating can
can help yeah I'm up a couple of points
in that session and let's see what we
can do next yeah this black game was a
bit awkward that I didn't get anything
interesting going there but yeah I mean
1e5 is what i usually play but i wanted
to play it in a more aggressive way
against the italian it's difficult let's
see if we get this again starting ok
woody with black and have now ok let's
go five and now let's go for something
aggressive hmm I actually think that
this is probably better than it looks
which is probably not saying much
because it looks a bit awkward but ok
it's not easy for him to play okay if I
go h3 you will take a phone I can take
and then go age three this is fairly
irritating again and let's now see what
i can do Knight to e5 maybe ok need to
be ready to recapture them ok ok it's
playing well he's playing well I think
can I take a four-night chicks if I mean
there should be seven 93 takes on dat
takes on d1 I don't think it's works now
that's not going to work yeah I took too
long here yeah I have to get get used to
them the time control that's really am
three minutes essence is really
something entirely entirely different
225 you have to be really decidedly
quicker it's just a just something
something else ok try to
I hope that he takes it's a bit of hope
chassis him bishop f4 was stronger but
ok he did take yeah I'm a pawn on age
three yeah it's not clear that this is
ever going to help me but ok now after
f4 I'm pretty I have some hopes that it
might ultimately lead to something f4
was a bit surprising ok maybe ok I can
take with the Queen not so don't know
yeah let's stick with the night unsure
I'm sure he has be still has a better
position but I was a bit surprised that
him that he went for this for this F
form it looks a bit weakening ok go to
his 65 Queen g5 it's not good ok I
cannot really do anything else ok night
to 2d six so what he wants to do it's
difficult really difficult to prevent ok
I really had to take that that I wasn't
wasn't much choice you can take with
them with the rook that's a problem hmm
yeah it's just just an exchange for
nothing much the only thing is that okay
taking this and no we're here maybe that
I have rook c8 the only thing is that
there's still this age three pawn which
is awkward what is he doing against that
move I'm threatening made and the
rookies hanging ha ok Jack and shake me
there but if I just step away or 2a8 for
that matter it's probably easier there's
no check at all and i'm still attacking
the rook and queen g2 made yeah I'm just
playing for cheap Trick's yeah it works
um okay check check him time morning
chat another check coming hmm there's no
major hard to believe we have five or
something I don't know it takes Knight
takes a certainty winning the thought
here there should be a witness well
Quincy three maybe
I'm not sure that was stupid f5 got 30
seconds left okay those checks didn't
help okay let's protect the point for
the moment and go from there and I still
don't see a bag there let's start with
Tim some chicks where is the maid I have
to use my night some somehow connect
with blundering am I going to win this
hmm Jack I don't see a win that sets the
sad truth Queenie to chick looks
dangerous check
where's he going beeping to h4 night
efore check
ah 94 chick I only have eight seconds
check
check
check check hey honey hope is my quick
pause him and and pre moving all of them
all of the time check
check aim yeah oh ok I gotta draw all of
that with absolutely well last last yeah
okay of course I have to win I didn't
find them meet their yeah okay three
minutes is really tricky for me it I
don't have the real feeling for that and
all of a sudden I was really really low
the temple is just more quickly here but
ok I think it was it was good fun the
age three Pawn yeah this is this
dangerous one was ultimately giving me
this is double a check ok come on one or
two more games to two finish the session
okay come on nobody in the three-minute
pool it's not very populated at the
moment it seems there are a couple of
game started good ones in there but ohio
i accidentally played deform ok but i
can transfer a transfer to them to the
to the French let's let's try to be
aggressive there ok here you always get
something aggressive going ok 27 mmm ok
and that's not happening that often they
very often go for go for Bishop f8 ok
maybe do this and night coming to age
form not sure if I want to take though
but ok I'm going to do that night up to
f1 here we go ok to cancel long here
yeah I have a nice position there with
the night on f4 but he has some managed
to yeah he has gotten rid of ism and
problematic LightSquared bishop still I
think that should be quite nice for me
huh a three what is he doing then taking
probably I can also take c 5 i'm not
sure that this is a very solid King
position that he has if he takes with
the pawn it looks really loose this king
and tonight on peace captures ok some
how to do that night if form ok let's
make sure that 94
hitting I still have other moves here
like a three and things or just nighty
too actually yeah I can protect you five
I could have taken g5 actually hmm night
CD 546 now he prevents it okay it's
still not a bad position and I don't
mind that that a bit I don't mind that
one bit disposition okay be sure before
I guess or B form I don't know be sure
before maybe that has that still keeps
the idea of c-4 in the position of
course after see form he has Queen a4 so
it's nothing that I can play immediately
ok let's play it simple if I take them
after pawn takes his king is in trouble
and here I have roots III coming
so let's see d4d force what he wants to
do mmm but my Rukia is protected so it's
not a huge deal yeah I know if I've
hangs but d4 hangs as well so it's
nothing that is very dangerous in
particular I think oh okay I didn't see
that one coming take through Kings still
queen of two nite if five does he have a
tactic I wonder it looks a little bit it
looks a bit vulnerable my position time
when I don't don't see a tactic at the
moment yeah okay now I'm threatening to
play be four winning winning annoyed oh
he's allowing the Shakya I think I'm
taking this opportunity and now I can
take them Knight takes are up chicks
have you up chicks rook takes all night
x look G tuned for the back rank
and I takes us a self-penned okay can
take on g2 I play look everyone then I
sorry Queen f1 was my idea but he has
night before I am maybe stuff like that
that could be a problem okay I can give
him checks there dat seven ah what a
shame don't have a square for that night
f8 looks terrible yeah wow it was such a
nice position and exported unfortunately
have to cover up g one now came a time
it was stupid I cannot make the time
that's a problem the position is may be
playable again and but I have to play
super quickly here check it's making
some mistakes they are but Jay question
is exactly if it is irrelevant black
time you have forfeited on time okay
that was a bit a bit lucky I had a very
nice position there but I screwed it up
with this the spec rank stuff yes all of
a sudden I couldn't hit couldn't take
only six it's kind of weird yeah
computers showing no respect here c 3 +
+ 5 that's funny + 5 it is giving as e6
is collapsing yeah i was thinking i
should have a nice
they have ignited strong enough
warranties really am having many
weaknesses but ok c 3 is very strong it
takes those squares away and it it does
break this kind of situation you're on
the rook a very nice okay but as
mentioned it's a it's not meant to be
very serious i'm not going to serious I
am yeah well not to yeah I don't want to
do many much of an elegy edges to play a
couple of fun games for I hope also your
enjoyment and then mine okay i hope you
liked it this was the first part of what
might become an on-and-off series yeah
thanks for watching bye